what's the difference between machine  learning and AI you mean outside of the  fact that AI sounds great for marketing  materials really Nick my bad AI is  normally broken down into two key  segments broad Ai and narrow AI broad AI  usually refers to the All-Seeing and  all-being artificial general  intelligence this is truly a free  thinking computer-generated brain  without getting too technical narrow AI  on the other hand normally refers to  Niche use cases where we can use  techniques like machine learning to  solve common problems machine learning  is the process that enables this it's  the process that allows computers to  learn you see in traditional programming  we take data Plus rules and we get  answers when we use machine learning on  the other hand we take data plus  historical answers to generate a new set  of machine learning generated rules or  logic we can then pass new data to the  ml model to solve problems like speech  to text image generation and object  detection